foreign
[Music]
ah
um Shanti
Shanti Shanti
translation let us be together let us
nourish ourselves together let us create
energy together let us grow in energy
together let there be no ill feelings
amongst us let there be peace let there
be peace let there be peace
the word is more divided than ever
globalization is there nationalism is on
the rise and it's me first everywhere at
least that's what our headlines have us
believe while we are here at me to be
and yet somehow I feel both the
narratives have something amiss what if
I told you it's always been a v let me
show you how let's start with my journey
here I discovered about the auditions
for today's shots while on my trip to
Egypt the one thing that stayed with me
from that trip is how similar we've
become as a society in our likes
dislikes interests aspirations and our
habits
the universality of this experience
stayed with me and I decided to talk
about it in my auditions
now somehow all the communications with
regards to my shortlist went into my
spam and I only discovered two weeks
back that I was selected not sure if I
was still on and not wanting to miss me
TV I decided to write till Elaine asking
her if it's too late now to say sorry
cause I don't want to be missing me do
we to which the lane replied it's too
late to
apologize it's too late to which I said
please she said make us an offer we
can't refuse I said I'll do whatever it
takes she said okay you're on assuming I
was through the obstacles I got to
Preparing only to find out that my
passport had expired as well
now don't worry I haven't climbed a wall
to be here the reason I'm here standing
in front of you is because of the
collective action of many everybody from
the passport officer the local cops my
family friends and the hundred thousand
guards they prayed to in short I'm
standing right here
now I know my personal story is
anecdotal it may not be relevant for
everyone so let's go to something more
relatable let's move to our story
if you think about it it's nothing short
of a miracle that us the puny little
bipedal Homo sapiens survive the hostile
environment we were born in
what made this miracle happen was our
unique ability to communicate but more
importantly leverage that for Collective
action
we would have been but a drop of water
evaporated by the wrath of time had it
not been for this ability today we are
in Ocean of us seven billion of us to
probably a problem at this point
so let's now you may say that hey this
is years back this is ancient history
and does not hold relevant at a time
when languages have evolved
nationalities have come in and so has
culture so let's look at a few cultural
examples let's start with an example
from India
this is the famous Indian footballer
from the Indian state of Kerala Leonard
and Messiah just kidding it is Lionel
Messi from Argentina but he's loved by
the state of Kerala like he's one of
their own they have cut outs of him
everywhere one of them is even a tourist
attraction on Google Maps
right
um or let's go to a more Global
phenomenon the BDS if I told you eight
decades back that a Korean band would be
most consumed in Japan would you believe
me in fact 90 of the viewership comes
from parts of the world that don't even
understand the language that they sing
in right and talking about language
Jungkook from the boy band was heard
listening to natu natu from the Indian
movie RR which was initially made in
Telugu dubbed in the language of Hindi
released in Netflix with subtitles and
grew to Global Acclaim because of its
ability to connect with the most Primal
human instincts right uh now you may say
it's only cultural so let's talk about
learning millions of others millions and
me included have learned from Masters
like Andrew huberman from Stanford David
Sinclair from Harvard vimhof sadhguru
and Yankee about various skills in life
the problems they talk about are
Universal and the solutions they're
giving are Universal and hence they have
the following that they have in fact
let's look at any moment that has turned
into a movement any individual that has
turned to a leader it is only happened
when they have understood that it's only
together we can make things happen
now I know entertainment culture and I'm
in GSB so I should be able to show you
guys the money so let's talk about
business two commonly asked questions to
business Founders are what is your Tam
total addressable market and how do you
plan to scale your product essentially
both these questions are asking you how
Universal is the problems that you're
solving right and some of the biggest
companies of our time have understood
that let's look at the fan companies
right Facebook solves for the human need
for connection Amazon solves the human
need for instant gratification Apple
sells for the human need of convenience
and Prestige Netflix solves for the
human need to be entertained and Google
solves for the human inquisitiveness
let's look at startup startups that have
gone through boom and bus cycles and
survived are the ones that are solving a
problem that is applicable to human
beings at large now you may say
businesses have profit motive they will
always find a way to make things happen
so let's look in a more unifying example
the pandemic right the covid-19 pandemic
was the first example in our living
times where we realized however
individualistic we may choose to be Our
Fate as humanity is collective right we
were all collectively locked down
uh and what got us together is a complex
Global Supply Chain where everyone did
their part the failure of one would have
meant the failure of all of us
and this you may say the pandemic is a
once in a lifetime event but there are
other problems staring at us as well
which are applicable to all of us
whether it's reducing attention spans I
see some of you looking at your phones
already whether it is uh the mental
health pandemic which is one in three of
us have mental health issues or it is
global warming there are problems that
are need our Collective acknowledgment
and our Collective application to solve
them
there's another Sanskrit saying that
goes like vasudeva kutumbakam the world
is one family an eccentric family but
one family nonetheless and it came way
before the term globalization was coined
and probably came from the understanding
that our successes and failures as
Humanity as Society are interlinked
there's a quote from a popular leader as
well the most unifying leaders of our
time as I see it we are one you and I
like the Earth and Sky one family Under
the Sun all the courage to lead all the
wisdom that you need you will find when
you see We Are One
the code is from Simba from Lion King 2.
but the message still holds true right
um
it has never been a me it is we may
choose to divide ourselves for a
convenience or for our own agendas but
it has never been in me it is never
needs to be moving from me to be it has
always been a v it's just that we have
been looking at the mirror from the
wrong direction thank you thank you so
much
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]